[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
corporate chess league as always my name
is caleb denby and i'm going to be your
host here tonight uh we are nearing the
end of our spring season for the the
corporate chess league actually and so
it's actually coming down to the wire
here these teams of course are competing
to see who is going to advance to the
playoffs and ultimately who will get
their name inscribed on the coveted
corporate chess league board you saw
alex there introducing everything he of
course is the league commissioner and
also a mainstay of the edward jones uh
corporate chess league team
and now we've got quite a few other
teams to take a look at here tonight so
why don't we see where they all stand as
we are in the back half of our grand
prix season uh up there you see
enterprise is the team leading the way
uh actually ahead of league uh you know
eternal league favorite edward jones
edward jones though does come in a solid
second place uh i would say though the
story of the league so far has been this
ascension team enterprise and edward
jones have been
pretty much totally dominant in
years past but i think ascension in this
season has taken match points off of
both enterprise and edward jones so they
are a team to look out for in the finals
and then for playoff contention the
battle is going to be going on between
doherty and bayer uh they are neck and
neck and only the top four will advance
to the playoffs so they have a lot to
play for here in these last few grand
prix matches
uh tonight we've got some exciting
matchups we have actually in round one
enterprise squaring off against edward
jones so we'll see the top two boards uh
battling it out there and then we have
ascension also squaring off against
bayer and if i'm not mistaken i think we
have no darty here tonight so this will
be bayer's chance to make up some points
see if they can replace darty in that
top four and make their way into the
playoffs
uh if you're wondering uh how this
actually all comes together the players
will all be playing two games per round
on chess.com the games are 10 plus 0. no
increment no delay you just get 10
minutes for the entire game after they
finish their first game they flip colors
and play again and that is what
constitutes the match how do those grand
prix points work that you saw well if
you win your match if your team beats
the other team then you get 20 extra
grand prix points on top of that you get
your team's total score in the match so
if my team plays your team my team
scores three points your team scores one
i get three plus 20 for a total of 23.
your team walks away with a measly one
point all right without further ado
though i do think games are underway and
i do mean games plural that's right we
have more than just make a cake to
follow here tonight why don't we take a
look at what's going on it looks like we
have board one of enterprise versus
edward jones already underway that's
right we've got the eternal kamikaze
knights uh leader of the enterprise team
john boyer up against justini
linguini who is a force to be reckoned
with now justini has had some big shoes
to fill here with vishal bardwage the
former edward jones uh board one leaving
the team
leaving the team uh in fact leaving the
entire company i think he got a new job
uh so justine tried to fill those shoes
on board one it's been sort of tough so
far board one is very competitive in
this league
uh but
he's going to do his best here to stop
john boyer in his tracks
by the way hello everybody in the chat i
do see you there thanks for joining here
tonight see james cloose cheese tiger
christian
james kluse
no i already said james cloose i got
confused i thought there were two clues
and christian again how's it going
all right let's take a look let's see
how we got here it looks like we had
appearance of some kind
um
so how did we get here
so d4 knight f6 knight c3 g6 very weird
move order but we do end up in a main
line uh here it's
sort of main line i i don't know in this
opening that well
and black is playing knight back to e8
and bishop g4 and wow bishop d5 this
looks very very strange by john i
i don't understand
what this move is i guess john was
worried about some sort of pressure on
f3 when the queen is pressuring d4 but
bishop d5 is very much an odd way to try
and solve that problem i think c6 is a
desirable move for black don't see any
reason not to to go go for something
like that
i guess in the long run black is going
to be trying to play c5 which is maybe
why uh justine chose queen to c8 instead
now h3 kicks this bishop away uh maybe
bishop back to f5 and maybe i'm i'm out
of my depth here maybe this is
uh this is this is you know all
according to plan but i have my doubts
about this bishop d5 move
struggle
it may look like black is getting rolled
over in the center you know white has
these two strong central pawns
but uh black is actually you know the
one with a little bit uh
a very safe king here so far in the long
run black might look to play something
like f6 to challenge this e5 pawn or of
course the the more normal plan c5
taking out this d4 pawn
e6 now comes with tempo but i don't love
this move at all by justinia i feel like
this is not what you want to be doing
here you actually
stunt your own light squared pieces and
you make this f6 move much harder to
achieve you always wanted to do f6 ef6
and now that that option's not going to
be available for you
this was the austrian attack yeah i
think i think you're right
um
did i call it the classical i think i
said it was just the main line
um and again maybe i'm out of my depth
here and both players know this better
than i do but
e6 look kind of looks kind of ugly i
don't know i don't know about that one
okay bishop c6 and castles
um after making the light squared bishop
bad i guess it makes sense that black
needs to trade it
uh and yeah now john i think is playing
a little bit more normally i don't know
what this whole maneuver is all about to
be honest with you maybe it's something
maybe it's not
okay queen back out to d7 now uh i mean
i'm not really sure
how much this move achieves black is
just gonna have a very tough time
getting all the pieces developed here
like
where where is this knight gonna go how
are you actually getting c5 and if
you're not getting c5 then you're
probably just very very sad in this
position white has a pretty clean plan
here you can just slowly but surely
maybe double up on this f file here play
move like knight g5 play a move like you
know eventually maybe we will take and
start bringing in this this other knight
and it's sort of a ready-made attack
pressure down the file and
the black king is going to start feeling
the pressure
he will not attack with pawns whites so
white already has this huge spatial
advantage and black has all these dark
squared weaknesses so i think here
rather than maybe something like h4h5
which actually also looks very good um
white can already just start trying to
play with the pieces just play move like
knight g5 here go after uh these
weaknesses
and and play some chess but h4h5 also
looks looks very good also looks very
good yeah hello to sams how's it going
hello hello okay so knight a6 is how
justine wants to get developed but it's
just very um
uncoordinated in my opinion you know
these these four pieces they don't seem
to have much to do with each other if
that makes sense right this knight is
stuck on the back rank this bishop's
looking at the center this bishop at
least is trying to trade itself off but
this knight also sort of out out in no
man's land you know none of these pieces
make sense together whereas with white
you can really see see the the through
line so to speak you see this knight
coming to e4 you see this knight coming
to g5 you see these bishops and this
bishop and queen pressuring the king's
side everything is starting to flow
together
and hello to dima on youtube thank you
for joining
a3 is a good move knight b4 i guess was
was actually kind of annoying so it
makes sense to stop it and now we do see
this trade and yeah black
absolutely needs to get c5 in or else
there's just nothing there's just no no
active counter play at all
need to get c5n how do you do it maybe
rook c8 but uh
i know it seems tough you would like to
play b6 but of course that leaves the
knight behind
whoops that leaves the knight behind
here so you can't do that
if you play c5 white will actually just
capture that pawn i think so it's
really unclear how we're getting c5
through is that a special coffee it's
just just a coffee
just a coffee to get me some energy uh
for this corporate chess league tonight
losing against the e5 pawn is black
lately yeah i mean there are a lot of
openings where white gets a big space
advantage in the center but what's
important is that whenever you play
those openings you need to have a very
clear plan for how you're going to
challenge the center
it's a good question webster so we were
actually looking at the game earlier
when black chose to play this e6 move
and i was really criticizing this one
because f6 of course is a very desirable
idea
in fact i might even play like king h8
here to try and achieve it maybe c6 is a
little bit uh
easier
um but yeah i very much wanted to play
f6 and after e6 it just becomes very
very difficult to ever to ever make work
because you don't want to leave this
pawn behind
um so i think that's really one of the
critical mistakes this game but and as
we see now black in fact is playing uh
f6 anyways but of course without the
pawn to be able to recapture you're
leaving behind number one the e5 square
number two these weaknesses
and
that's maybe the only two things that i
have to say but those are two pretty
major things um leaving behind all these
weaknesses not going to be uh pleasant
now if i'm playing with white here i'm
probably gonna go for c3 just to
solidify this pawn allow myself to play
knight e5 to follow up and put black in
a bad way
of course 95 immediately does drop this
pawn so that's why i wanted to play c3
but maybe black is onto something here
because if i do go c3 maybe c5 is is
finally back on the cards
so black did manage to give white some
problems to solve here which is uh
admirable considering how tight the grip
looked on the position
so it looks like f6 anyways was maybe
maybe not so bad
so how do we solve these problems with
white if we go c3 c5 knight e5 what
exactly is going on there
um
it looks like i'm attacking the knight
and the queen so maybe this is actually
very good hold on one two three
one two yeah it's also good immediately
we don't need this c3 move now if takes
on d4 we simply trade the queens take on
f6 and win a piece so
black is in fact just in a very bad in a
very bad spot here
you can go queen e7 to momentarily
defend everything but i think the simple
move knight g4 is gonna be enough when
again you can really see the the harmony
in white's position when literally every
minor piece plus a rook is attacking the
same square you know the the pieces all
work together and that's that's going to
give you a winning advantage here
yeah just knight g4 john finds it
jon finds it proving why he's the
highest rated player in the corporate
chess league
and if i can maybe refresh here
we might have some more games
oh no say it isn't so okay
i at least have two games to follow but
i'm not pulling up some of these other
games let's try unfollowing everybody
and we'll follow kamikaze knight we're
already observing him and let's see if
we can observe board two how is kendalum
doing
oh boy
oh boy
no no pendulum all right well we've got
at least board one um
and
nick risco our tournament director here
tonight also having issues spectating
other games
so
looks like our
our problems with chess.coms might might
not be fully solved but hey we've got
board one of the the marquee match up
here what more can you ask for
we also have a second game by the way so
we can take a look at this as well
um just sticking with this momentarily
though it looks like after queen f7
black is going to be losing a piece so i
think jon is going to be able to wrap
that one up why don't we take another
look at
uh this game then between kyqz and
nc nick jm
by the way i had a moment here today on
the bayer team there are two people on
the bayer team two different people one
is named mcnick jm who we're watching
right now the other is named nmc gin
and i'm pretty sure in my brain up until
this very moment i thought that those
were the same person
um
anyways looks like m c nick jm
found a little idea look at that that's
gonna be checkmate you have to play rook
f2 otherwise queen to h2 is checkmate
you cannot capture this bishop that's a
nice little find nice tactic by mc
so rook f2 is played but now queen to h2
is still playable it's not checkmate
anymore but you do
pick up at least an exchange
very nice find very very nice find
bishop e3
upset and a half well it's not over yet
it's not over yet
um it is just an exchange
um so yeah bishop f2 first also is good
enough to win when the exchange oh king
takes is bold i would have gone queen
takes to try and guard some of these
dark squares
uh king takes just invites
invites the wolf to the hen house as
yester would say
um yeah either the queen or the rook
both look pretty reasonable here maybe
what um kyqz is hoping for is that uh
black will get a little ambitious forget
about his own king
and start uh
and allow this this white queen to come
in and maybe deliver some checks maybe
pick up the e6 pawn something like that
uh no such luck mc keeps it together
makes another threat of rook to f8
and keeps his ideas alive over on this
side of the board as well
king e2 makes sense um
if i'm black i'm probably going to play
rook fade anyways yeah get this queen
off this nice open file where it works
well with the bishop and once this queen
leaves maybe to h3 or something i think
i want to play e5 and after e5 i just
want to rip open the center get to this
white king and
cause some more problems for my opponent
all right don't want to jump around too
much but we will check in on our other
game here looks like uh john boyer did
uh end up winning that first match uh of
course he was just winning that piece on
f6
so
let's see how they do in their second
game of the match we have a little a6 a
little a6 idea by john boyer uh
justini decides to go for the exchange
and with this weird bishop g5 move this
is not at all standard by uh justini
normally they put this bishop on f4
let's see what he has in mind
let's see what he has in mind here
okay knight e4 just e3
just lets him take
okay i don't know how i feel about all
this don't know how i feel about all
this okay takes takes and john boyer has
the bishop's pair and he also gets this
nice e5 move
yeah something has gone wrong here
something has gone wrong here for uh
for white
it's a london not quite it's a slav
it's a slav
it's not a london when white puts the
pawn on c4
um
yeah it's an exchange slot but yeah
bishop g5 very very strange in fact
after knight e4 like you sort of feel
like you have to take this guy you sort
of feel like you have to do it but after
pawn takes maybe there's just no good
square for the knight if you go back to
d2 queen takes d4 might be on the cards
so
already kind of tough for for white i
would already i think prefer black here
but we will leave this game for a moment
i want to see the big finish to this
game what happened it looks like e5 did
in fact happen
um yes so we got e5 after rook f4 though
and then there's a check
and white picks up this pawn but loses
the g pawn
now both sides with the past pawn but of
course this should favor black uh due to
having the rook if i'm black here i'm
just going to play king to e6
attacking this pawn
on e5 and after king to
d4
um
i was sort of wondering if i could even
just take on e4 what's uh what mc is
doing here is also just just very good
now you can play king to e6 and there's
no way even to defend this pawn
so
even simpler
even simpler here
the only danger of course is the danger
that is ever present and that is the
clock just a minute 37 for for mc we'll
see if he has the uh
the speed chest skills to to pull this
one off
okay now we just need to push this guy
the nice thing about playing against a
bishop when you're low on time is that
if you put all your pieces on the other
color square then it can't really hurt
you you know you can play very quickly
if you have all your pieces on the dark
squares against a light squared bishop
that being said though he needs to to
make some progress here he can't dilly
dally for too long or else the the clock
will start to to be a problem
yeah i
i'm a little bit confused by his choice
of placing this rook here on h4 but
uh looks like he's getting away with it
look like looks like nothing is going
too wrong he can come down to h2 now
swing over collect some of these pawns
and just just make it easy just make it
easy
yeah if you're black here and you're
sitting here with a minute under clock
trying to calculate to checkmate don't
do that just just go rook b2 take the b
pawn you know just just take some of
these pawns off the board just make your
life easy
no need to play perfect chess
you just need to play winning chess
okay he takes my advice goes rick b2
takes takes on b6
okay
bishop e6 is kind of weird
um i would have taken the pawn but king
to e3 is is fine as well
okay now he takes i guess we're coming
back to f4 uh we could also go to d4 i
suppose but
yeah no rush here no rush here for black
just play simple moves quickly
and you will you will find your way
rook to b4 now makes things very easy
okay rook to b2 check isn't going to
spoil anything either oh that's
checkmate in one
that is checkmate in one
checkmate in one
checkmate in one
check mate
check mate
checkmate
yay all right he got him he got him big
upset for mc congratulations to bayer
getting it done on board one when they
really needed to
all right let's check back in on this
weird-looking slob game how on
earth
did this happen
okay we got f4 knight to c6 queen to a4
bishop d7 yes somehow white's opening is
looking like it's getting justified here
yeah
allowing this this 95 f4 business uh
feels like maybe it shouldn't have
happened i had a
i had a dumb idea here of playing some
move like uh
like like this but maybe it's no good
maybe there is just queen to a4
and this knight is going to be able to
trade itself off of course my threat
with h5 okay maybe it's not a threat i
want to trap this i wanted to trap this
knight somehow some f6 move at some
moment maybe even here
and then i don't be greedy and try to
win the knight but i just try to harass
it a little bit go f6h5 put this knight
back on a dumb square like like f2
something like that might have made
sense you could also maybe take on f3
uh just keep things simple give white
this sort of soft looking pawn structure
but after knight c6 bishop d7 now all of
a sudden it's getting tough it's getting
very very tough for black to hold this
together
yeah and that's why you see john finally
spending some time here justine also
tanking in the opening it's moved 13 and
he's used almost half his time
but
looks like he's getting it done
okay he just chops on the e5 square now
how to take back
this this one is not so simple i think i
you know i i want to take with the d
pawn and the reason why is i want to be
able to put my rook on d1 targeting this
uh backwards d-pawn the danger though is
that we are missing our dark squared
bishop and black is going to be able to
come out with c5 bishop c5 and uh sort
of strike right at the heart of our uh
our weakness here on on e3 the heart of
our pawn structure
so rick d1 is played but again this
bishop c5 move is what you have to look
out for
okay queen to a5 is sort of a weird
a weird way to hold the balance king f2
is a desirable move for white so i'm not
sure why john is trying to induce it
maybe he wants to play rook to d8 just
to
play some defense here again i think the
the active counter play with bishop to
c5 was was where it was at
although maybe yeah maybe knight takes
d5 was was a reasonable response
maybe bishop d5 or sorry maybe knight d5
was a good response 9294 looks desirable
yeah this is also on the cards for white
uh
this is really you know black's main
source of play here you just have to
make sure this bishop c5 and this
diagonal isn't going to kill you and if
it doesn't i think you're in you're in
good shape
see i'm with you webster we gotta go
king f2 uh white does find it
and yeah now we have our threats here we
have our repositioning idea here this
bishop looks a little silly and the the
center is closed enough that i don't
think the bishops are are going to hurt
too bad
at least not for now
black of course does have some ideas
though you can go f6 you can chop off
this e5 pawn try to get your bishop to
a little bit of a better diagonal
but this light squared bishop is going
to remain a problem for some time here
it's going to remain a problem
yeah that being said though i do like
ideas like f6 you know rook d8 is makes
sense to start with we we did have uh a
problem here on d5 but now if i'm black
i kind of want to castle i kind of want
to play f6 and i want to go uh use this
f file try to get at this white king see
if i can shake something loose
white king f2
uh
so
our idea with white here was to pressure
this weak pawn on the open d file so
justine went rook d1 so we're
threatening to play knight takes d5
black's response to this was to go queen
a5 which pins our knights and a very
convenient move for white here is king
f2 because it unpins the knight steps
out of this pin and it also defends our
weakness our other concern was that
black might go after this e3 pawn so
king f2 solves this problem anticipates
the attack on e3 helps you defend this
guy and in the long run you're going to
be able to develop your bishop and
immediately connect your rooks so it's
just a good multi-purpose move covers e3
unpins the knight helps develop towards
connecting the rooks and that's why it's
a good one
okay white chose to bring out this
bishop to h3 i'm not sure what we're
doing on this diagonal i guess he wanted
this e2 square for the knight which
which makes some sense so i'm expecting
92 here you have to be very very
cautious otherwise black might play d4
and once d4 happens if diagonals start
to open up you're going to regret you're
going to regret this bishop pair you're
going to regret that
so i think knight e2 is a must
don't think you can get away with knot92
maybe he's trying to calculate this but
of course there's bishop takes e3
tactics so knight d5 we'll just take
take take take bishop e3 win the queen
that's the end of the calculation
okay 92 played
92 played
um wait a second though did i blunder
i might have blundered
it looks like i blundered
don't tell anybody
don't tell anybody
yeah that's uh that's unfortunate for
white here that's unfortunate i always
have to look out for the simple tactics
yeah bishop a4 of course john finds it
and yeah it you know we we went back and
forth a few times i think white just
played a few weird moves here i liked
this position um you can't play 92 right
away because of the same tactic but
um
but what
but yeah i don't know this g3 bishop h3
like maneuver just didn't seem like the
right way to get developed it's a bit
too slow it's a bit too nonchalant for
what the position was uh
was calling for there
yeah so now bishop a4 and white will
lose some material
unfortunate
maybe you know maybe you could at least
try taking on b7 get like a pawn for the
uh for the exchange i understand it
looks a little bit risky you know
opening up this file with when our king
is so exposed but
i think you needed to at least get
something for it you know
always better to have you know something
for it
uh rather than uh than nothing and you
can quote me on that that's chess wisdom
right there it's better to have
something than nothing
truer than
most other chess principles you're going
to hear
yeah bishop b4 this is just another
reason why queen c3 doesn't look quite
quite right
you can play queen to d4 but our queen
actually doesn't really want to be here
that's the square our knight wants to be
on the only other option is queen to c1
which obviously is also not not entirely
ideal
yeah webster also missed this one
uh
easy one to miss i guess you're not
expecting black to have a random tactic
in this position for sure
all right queen d4 is played but again
the queen isn't actually that
comfortable in this square in my opinion
all right let's check out uh this other
game going on then let's see what we got
here how did we get here we had a
sicilian a queen takes sicilian wow
okay i again i'm out of my depth on this
one
um these rare e4 lines
okay well knight e5 knight takes d3 yeah
i don't know how i feel about that one
by black i would uh rather keep this
knight here for a little bit this bishop
is
not exactly comfortable on d3
and it has nowhere to go uh so that's
another chess principle don't take
things that can't run away um that
that's
actually a real one for you this time so
i would have left the knight on e5 for a
little bit longer done something useful
maybe a6 maybe rook c8 just something
useful instead
uh before revealing my intentions
um and then we got this knight d7
maneuver okay white gets this nice
knight on d5 but it looks like
b2 was hung yeah b2 is just hung
okay so it's not the end of the world
for white yetz
not down in exchange or anything just
down a pawn
but black's pieces have all sort of
invaded here so tough position for sure
for for mc
tough position for sure
okay rook back to b1 i mean he's he's
still fighting he is just down one pawn
but you can see the the activity this
knight is on a great square on c5 you
can also see how this bishop sort of
dominates white's center right it's
tough to make any progress to push the
center
when um when this bishop controls those
dark squares so well
uh that being said we still have the
shining jewel of our position here uh
with this knight on d5
this knight on d5 is such a shining
jewel that it might as well be attending
st louis university
a bit of a deep cut joke for you guys
there
random tactics when you're playing all
the right ideas are unfortunate to miss
because you feel like you should be
rewarded not punished yeah i mean that's
chess chess is definitely a game of
specifics uh just because you know the
general idea doesn't mean it's the right
idea in that specific position gotta be
on the lookout
don't take things that can't run away
yeah i didn't come up with that one that
one is something that that you know
normal people actually say as well
but it's it's useful it's useful if it
can't run away then you might as well do
something else useful leave that bishop
sort of in the way of your opponent
before you clarify the position it's the
same idea behind keeping the tension you
know if
you leave things in the air then your
opponent has more things to deal with
okay this just looks very good for for
black though i'm going to switch back
over to the main event here
of course we saw whites blunder this
rook on d1 just the same as as we all
did here on the stream
um and then we got this little maneuver
black does still have this dark squared
pressure
and then bam a sacrifice
wow
okay so a counter sacrifice i might have
gone for for the e4 pawn instead allowed
e3 check and when maybe i can just play
queen back to uh to this square i don't
know how the tactics work out though
um looks like we're just trading into an
exchange down end game now
white is going to be able to pick up
this pawn on e4 in the long run uh but
black can actually make that difficult
as well and while you're picking up that
pawn you know look out for your other
pawns that are gonna start to drop uh
that's not where the bad news ends
though 15 seconds for justini to john's
three minutes not going to be good
enough not going to be good enough at
all here
this will be disaster for justini so
john boyer gets a quick 2-0 on board one
for the enterprise versus edward jones
matchup
so let's uh you know hopefully i didn't
just jinx him but i'm pretty sure he's
gonna win that game so let's stick with
uh this other game then because there is
still some intrigue here
still just one pawn down for whites the
a pawn seems to be the next target
though along with this bishop on d2 uh
white can uh
sort of keep things murky by playing
something like bishop to g5
uh i'm more familiar with this pawn
structure from things like the benko
gambit but bishop g5 is often just sort
of awkward for black to deal with here
this e7 pawn is definitely
a sore spot for for black
and there's not a super comfortable way
to defend it you don't want to go f6
stunting your bishop you don't want to
go e6
weakening the dark squares usually
something like king f8 is the best you
can do
while i was talking though white played
queen e3 which of course blunders the
bishop so the bishop was captured and
everything i was just talking about no
longer matters
no longer matters
when i lose my queen i start singing
ain't no sunshine when she's gone
yeah you know i can't say i've ever done
that but it's not the worst idea singing
at the chessboard
not the worst idea so john does go on to
win that game
um
just by resignation it looks like the
bishop got got blundered yeah bishop c8
not so good three seconds on the clock
as well never really stood a chance
and that leaves us with just this game
to follow for now
was this uh okay rook c1 knight takes a5
okay you saw it here you saw it here
okay
um i can't make too much fun this is a
sort of blindness that uh
that happens sometimes in chess i i
think everybody's sort of guilty of this
you know
you don't often see somebody just
blunder a full rook like this and so
whenever it happens and you already like
made another threat you're just happy
that they didn't defend against your
threat you don't even really look at
what move they played and you just take
the pawn so i think that's what happened
here
not going to change the outcome of the
game
not going to change the outcome of the
game
probably
probably
okay knight c5 black gives up a pawn in
order to trade off the knights not
really a bad idea in this position
especially because you get rooked to b8
and now it's going to be smooth sailing
this pawn just goes
pawn goes
passive pawn gets pushed
looks like we're getting some results
coming in
so we followed board one of that
enterprise match up and kamikaze knight
we saw him go 2-0 against justini
linguini on the other boards it looks
like pendulum for enterprise
won one and a half to half a point
against fishers of ben for edward jones
and on board three big daddy jazz 64
split his match against paul frowen so
enterprise does win that head-to-head
matchup so they will be getting that
20-point bonus towards the grand prix
and in this ascension versus bayer match
ah it's not looking good for bear mc
needed to win this game to tie the match
and now actually we just see that he has
officially resigned the match instead
so with that loss ascension does defeat
bayer as well they are only getting
um two points on the three boards
so what happened there the head-to-head
matchups were kyqz goes 1-1 against
mcnick jm with that big upset in the
first game that they played
and then board two is where ascension
wins the match maurice gp gets 2-0
against vindy and on board three s
gilmore split his match against nmc gin
who is not mc nick jm very different
people um so maurice taking home that
match victory for ascension
okay
so with that i think we are just about
ready to move on to round two maybe
we'll have more games to follow
although i sort of like the the chill
you know we only follow a couple games
sort of uh sort of way to play here
um we get to follow some board one games
we get to see the best of the best
and sometimes it works out
um so i don't think round two has
started yet so we are waiting for just a
moment let's go ahead and see what
matchups we have
uh what's my rating i am around 22
hundred something uscf uh 22.70
something i think
and i'm trying to get 2200 feet i'm
battling i'm battling i'll be battling
tomorrow in st louis we've got an
exciting tournament coming up in person
it's going to be feed a rated
and we'll see uh we'll see what happens
the bill wright st louis open of course
if you're in the area check it out it's
going to be a lot of fun
anyways board two of the corporate chess
league we have
uh enterprise up against bayer and we
have edward jones up against ascension
so we're gonna see justine linguini take
on kyqz we're gonna see john boyer take
on mcnick jm we'll see if mc can
continue
uh with the massive upsets it's going to
be tough against john
going to be tough for sure
and justini definitely looking for
redemption for edward jones he's got a
battle kyqz
also where is alex kirford where is alex
alex always plays i think he's missed
the last two events for edward jones the
team needs him team needs you alex come
back
come back
right i'm gonna refresh one more time
we'll see what we got going on here
oh that doesn't look right
okay
i think a lot of these people uh clicked
out of chess.com hopefully they find
their way back in lots of unable to
follows here so here's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna unfollow everybody to start
with
stop being a creep you know not gonna
follow anybody
and then we're gonna do this magic url
thing again
okay i'm at least following these people
indiana jones 2020 is our house player
here tonight shout out to adi thank you
for filling in here playing some of the
extra games for when we have an odd
number of players
but yeah we're at least following
kamikaze knight and justine linguini so
we will be able to to see those top
games again
round two starts at seven
wow okay strict schedule for the
tournament here tonight so
we've got some time what do you guys
want to talk about what do you guys want
to talk about i know what to talk about
do you live in the st louis area do you
want to get involved with the corporate
chess league well i'll tell you what to
do number one you can go to our website
and go under uh i think it's oh boy i
think it's like uh join or something
join and give i think under joining give
we have the corporate chess league uh
it's somewhere on our website check it
out or you can email us at development
stlouischestclub.org below me i love
doing this i never get to do this i get
to point at graphics it's amazing
development at st louis chessclub.org
send us an email get involved we'd love
to have you join these events are a lot
of fun we've been doing them virtually
lately because of covid and because of
other things going on at the chess club
but uh when we do them in person they're
a lot of fun you get to come out you get
to socialize a little bit do some
networking you're all businessy and play
some chess have a good night so get
involved
uh you don't have to be good either uh
trust me trust me you don't have to be
good you just have to enjoy chess and
want to play some chess and then come
play chess that's all you have to do
that's really all that's involved
um well since we've got time uh
maybe i'll play a chess game you guys
want to play chess game it's been a
while
it's been a while we've got some time to
fill let's try it out let's play three
minute game
i love chess so i'm on my personal
account here here you'll have to forgive
me i am the llama lord and we'll see
what's going on well we'll get a d4
little d4 action
maybe playing f3 nimzo
do i ever go to the art museum
um i've been to the art museum not
recently
what companies compete in this i'm so
glad you asked uh tonight we have
enterprise uh bayer edward jones and
ascension uh playing and we are missing
guardi darty is normally also in these
events but i think they couldn't
compete tonight so hopefully they get to
come back for the next event
so cool
my username or the corporate chess
league or both
okay so i wasn't paying much attention
my opponent played bishop f5 and i just
played bishop to d3 which is sort of a
very friendly thing to do with white
um
very friendly just letting black trade
off my best minor piece but i just
wanted to keep things simple in this
blitz game
yeah you can go um queen f3 here and the
point is that uh
black has to deal with the doubling of
these f-pawns which is probably what i
would do in a serious game
but instead we're just going to keep it
simple here
uh i am actually going to take this no
i'm not i'm going to go knight g3 i'm
going to keep some pieces on i got an
iqp here
and i want to maybe target this f5
square and highlight that this bishop is
not so comfortable
not so comfortable
just because the light squared bishops
are off the board doesn't mean that the
light squares aren't important all right
i will come on this open e file now
the idea of a corporate league yeah it's
a lot of fun we have alex crawford to
thank for it um alex of course the lead
commissioner is the one who really
put in the work to recruit some some
teams and get everything together
where's ana sherovich i mean she's
around
i think she
just is focusing i think she has like a
job i think she has like a career so i
think she's probably been doing that
if i had to guess
you think that anyone can get to 2000 if
they train enough and learn theory
um i think almost anyone i mean if you
get like in a horrific car accident and
it's like
you know are
missing you know half your brain maybe
not but
i feel like most people could get there
um the trouble is you know that those
keywords if they train enough
because that's the the issue that most
adults run into turns out a lot of
people have like jobs or something that
takes up all their time and when you get
involved with these things
jobs
they take up a lot of time and it turns
out you don't have much time to focus on
just sitting around playing chess and
studying chess
so yes and and also no
all right i'll go b4 here my opponent
wants to play knight f4 so i'm going to
drop my bishop back keep an eye on that
square
i'm sort of eyeing this d6 square as
well just keeping an eye on things a5 is
a good move by my opponent though
definitely a good idea
maybe i want to go 95 i sort of want to
play b5
i think actually though instead of all
those things i do have to capture here
all right i'm gonna fake him out now i
was only pretending to want the e-file
what i really wanted to do was attack
your b-pawn
it was all a joke
okay rook a7 i'll go rook b3
i don't think i'm blundering the fork
you can play c5 but then this knight
gets a little bit destabilized so i
don't know if you really want to
i also am hoping i'm not blundering
backrank mate but i don't think i aim
either it's probably worthwhile for me
to play something like h3 here just uh
get that together oop we had a little
american cup flash on flash on the
screen there that was exciting
okay rook e6 very very quickly i guess
the time is
dwindling here
um i guess he was anticipating that rook
c1 move
okay i'm just gonna i'm gonna come in
here you play knight e5
in the take with the bishop
threaten something like queen g3 maybe
maybe i'll play queen f3
i don't know
russians remember anna okay
all right bishop b5 okay he finally
cracks he finally plays uh g6 which does
weaken some squares so i am going to
play queen to g3 sort of keep the
tension here
and see if i can't uh can't make
something happen maybe h4h5 is a way to
go okay queen to d2 he's trying to
invade i'm going to play h4 don't think
my opponent made a threat
we'll just keep it rolling here keep
some moves flowing
okay
all right maybe it is time to drop back
with the night maybe it's time
i mean what else am i gonna do what else
am i gonna do i'll come back
and i will actually start playing a bit
faster i think it's needed here
okay b4 finally got played
scary stuff
okay i'm gonna attack the queen
i'm gonna just let my opponent queen the
pawn for some reason
probably not the best idea
yeah probably not the best idea
okay
we'll do this
and this and let my opponent have an
extra queen
makes sense right
ah i lost on time
i'm the worst
all right well with that it's 6 59 at
least we filled the time
tough to play fast on on the setup we've
got here i'm i'm some distance away from
the monitor some distance away but
that's okay
all right with that i think we are just
about ready for round two oh that's my
name yeah caleb denby welcome if you're
just joining you missed the first round
of the corporate chess league but you
are just in time for round number two uh
what are we competing for we're
competing for grand prix points here
tonight the teams competing are hoping
to make the playoffs uh and the battle
is for bayer right now they are hoping
hoping to uh
score some grand prix points and pass
darty to make their way into the top
four so they can get into the playoffs
and have some fun
and with that i think i have filled
enough time as our first game has
started let us check it out we've got
justini linguini once again battling uh
kyqz
so this of course is the edward jones
versus ascension matchup
and again ascension sort of the dark
horse of this tournament so far
enterprise and edward jones have been
dominant in years past but ascension uh
in a very close third place
uh taking some points off of these
monster teams
uh so far no moves though no moves being
played
so there's your standings for tonight
enterprise and ascension uh picking up
the first two match wins and
surprisingly darty also got points okay
so i think what happened there is they
have one player competing here tonight
by the name of i love legos 2 one player
not enough to constitute a team but he's
still allowed to play in the extra
matches and the points that he scores
still goes towards the team total
so actually bayer has made up no ground
so far they need to win a match to
really leapfrog in the standings here
so what do we have it looks like we have
in advance french with this knight a3
move okay again the player's testing
theory that i know very very little
about
uh what's knight e3 what's going on here
what does knight takes d4 what's going
on here this is hanging
do you take this
i feel like you take this this feels
like
not the best of the ways to sacrifice
your e5 pawn like this
this feels like not the best way to
sacrifice your e5 pawn if if you ask me
i can think of one or two other ways i
would have done it you know you see
these lines with bishop d3 sacrificing
upon you see lines uh where you know
things get get opened up a little bit
earlier that you can play
but
yeah knight a3 with the idea of
sacrificing this pawn i don't know okay
you get bishop b5 check kyqz playing
very quickly as if this was the point
but now after this trade of bishops i
think black is doing very well blacks up
a pawn in the center
black has very easy development very
natural development bishop d6 knight f6
castle
what's the story what's the story here
what is the story
i'm not sure i know the story
okay a6 i i don't know how i feel about
that one i don't know how i feel about
a6 i guess they were worried about
knight b5 if they tried to go bishop d6
but what is there to be worried about
you know you've taken your pawn
uh when you take a pawn in the opening
it always costs you some time right you
spend time capturing upon
and so after you capture that pawn you
have to play very quickly you have to
develop your pieces with a sense of
urgency that way you can consolidate and
just be up a clean pawn now black still
got there in the end but you don't
really want to be spending time on moves
like a6 after you've just snatched a
pawn you want to be spending all your
time developing as quickly as you can
making sure you get consolidated making
sure your position is solid
that way you know you can enjoy your
extra pond instead of suffering for it
oh also yeah well webster with a super
chat shows up kind of weird on the
screen that i have here but thank you
very much
okay we get rook to c8s bishop takes c5
um and i i again i don't see the point
why didn't black play bishop takes
knight a3 um was it hanging at some
point or are you just asking about the
um
yeah just just the pawn structure so
bishop takes knight here is interesting
there's definitely an argument for doing
it because it very much makes white's
pawns ugly
the downside is when you play the french
these dark squares become rather loose
around your king you know you're putting
all your pawns on light squares so you
might be a little bit wary of giving up
that bishop for that knight especially
when things like you know bishop f4 can
come in and start eyeing up all these
loose squares around your king
that being said i'm sort of with you on
this one it looks like it's probably
just a good move in this instance
um but you know not entirely necessary
either black still is getting a good
position more than one way to get there
do the super chats go to caleb i can't
really tell what you said we're using
some uh
some website that combines youtube and
twitch chats
but here let me open up our actual
stream here let's see what i can see
[Music]
oh well it's just a super chat with no
text
well in that case i did see it
all right
thank you very much
would have totally taken that in blitz
at least yeah no i mean i think it's
it's perfectly viable actually why don't
we cheat here i'm curious what the
engine thinks because it's it is very
much a double-edged uh double-edged
thing let's see if the engine likes it
um yeah an engine is
is on the same page although i will say
it says this move is like minus 2.2 this
move is minus 2.0 so
there you go both moves good as expected
but you'll notice it's not like you know
a huge difference and that's because it
is sort of double-edged you know you
want to be careful about giving away
that bishop
um now i will say trading that bishop
for the other bishop much less risky
because you know obviously then it's uh
there's no unopposed bishop to worry
about like you can imagine if a bishop
is on a3 right now you know white might
have uh
something to play it for in this case
i think it's just sadness just sadness
and an extra pawn for for black that
being said i've seen much better
positions go down the drain in the
corporate chess league and just in chess
so
uh
still you know not not time to give up
just yet for kyqz
while they're figuring that one out
though let's check in on the this other
game that we've got going on which is
between kamikaze knight and mc
looks like we have a scandi here with b4
wow again just lines that i don't know
so i suppose the idea is that if you go
capturing this pawn white wants to go
something like rook b1 and target the b7
pawn
so black declines
and the queen continues to get pushed
around and then we end up with this
slightly strange structure
both sides get castled knight c4
is white's idea
b6
i don't know how i feel about that but
okay b6 c5 is the point and now after c5
white steps past with b5 we get a trade
of these knights and knight c6 and we're
back up to uh
back up to present day
super playable scandiline you've seen it
it's been seen at the master level this
b4 idea interesting i i was not familiar
um so what's going on here i liked what
uh john did by sort of sidestepping that
c5 pawn by playing b5 what that is going
to do for him is in the long run if we
end up in end games white's going to be
able to make a past pawn and a very far
advanced pass pawn over here on the
queen side in fact that's going to be
relevant in these middle games as well
meanwhile black is not without counter
plays he's targeting the c3 pawn a
little bit trying to make something
happen over on this side of the board
but to my eyes it looks like this a5 and
eventually b6 kind of game plan is going
to be
pretty relevant here
so you see black immediately trying to
challenge this idea i kind of like this
the point is that if you go a5 black is
simply going to play queen back to c7
and you're in this awkward spot where
you can't really touch your b pawn you
would love to play b6 but of course that
leaves this knight behind
so problems to solve here again for john
but so far tonight he's been on his game
he's been able to solve the problems his
opponents have been posing okay so he
does continue through with a5 now so
what's the idea queen to c7 what is what
does he want maybe he just wants
something like rook to b1 just keep it
simple if you take my guy i'll take back
with the bishop defend my knight
although i i have to say i'm not
entirely convinced by such things no he
wants the exchange sack all right i love
it bold chest by john he gives up the
rook in order to maintain this pawn duo
over here on the queen side
oh do they go to caleb no i don't get
the money from the super chats
what it does do is support our
scholastics program i believe if i can
read
our uh
our little blurbs somewhere maybe i
can't read our blurb but it goes to our
scholastics program i don't know the
blurb off the top of my head because i'm
not on the stream so much these days
but uh
it helps chess in schools this much i
know
okay so john sacrifices the exchange
what does he get for it he gets a past
b-pawn which is going to look very scary
it remains to be seen how useful it
actually is though so someday he's going
to play b6 he doesn't have to do it
immediately because he would very much
appreciate if black would capture here
giving him a past pawn uh two connected
pass pawns
instead he goes bishop f3
which looks like a very sensible move
you want to push this rook away
now black has to decide where it goes i
think b8 makes the most sense
uh you do have to be a little bit
worried about uh ba6 sometimes here and
that might be what jon has in mind we
can play queen to a7 but then he might
get stuck with bishop to b7 and i think
the best the black can do is start
giving back some of that material
okay same with bishop to f4 honestly if
i'm black here
i'm thinking about playing a takes b5
allowing bishop b8 rook b8 cb5 rook b5
the danger though is that this bishop is
already in prime position to control the
queening square so maybe that that in
fact would not not be working out right
white still has this past a pawn the
queen supports it queen or pawn to a6
immediately and
black might be in a bad way
so rook to d8 instead and we see now
pawn to b6 i think john is still
intending to do some very rude things
like bishop c7 uh the simpler way to
play of course is just b7 b8 these
bishops
uh already well placed to just escort
that pawn down the board
okay rook's a d4 though by black he's
fighting back he's fighting back
not taking it lying down
so it would be great if we could just
play b7 b8 but of course rook f4 takes
away our defender of the b8 square and
if white takes the time to play bishop
g3 i think black will in fact snap off
the c4 pawn after b7 he's just gonna go
rook over to b4 and try and corral this
b-pawn before it gets anywhere too scary
meaning you know the next square up the
board where it turns into a queen
seems like black's down a piece with
that bishop on g6 it so it looks like
that for the moment but this bishop is
actually useful in that line that i just
mentioned if we take and go rook b4
white would love to play rook b1 but
simply cannot thanks to this bishop uh
so in a sense it is kind of you know
biting on nothing uh it's it's just got
the open air to target but sometimes the
open air is is useful
so bishop e3 by john and uh chad asks
why not queen to c1 and sort of i'm
wondering the same thing maybe not c1
but you could go actually yeah i guess
you have to go c1 to defend both yeah i
mean that that defends both both threats
it certainly was worth considering said
bishop e3 and black does just capture
this pawn
uh maybe jon wants to play rook c1 here
and his idea is that he's going to be
winning the pawn back on c5
that very much could be the case
yeah the bishop on g6 does have some
scope i agree like you know there are
going to be a lot of variations where it
turns out to be a useful piece
uh so this was john's idea he wants to
skewer the rook and the pawn and again
he's going to get that past pawn duo
now that this has been allowed i have to
say i think that this is going to be
very
very difficult for um
for black to deal with i think rook to
b4 was definitely the better square um
you still lose this pawn on a6 but maybe
uh maybe you can fight back a little bit
right you get rook to a8 there bishop
retreats you have rook takes b6 with the
the pin on the queen
could have been interesting instead
though rick e4 and now it's just the a
pawn for nothing and yeah those those
pawns are going to roll down the board
white is is going to be crushing here
were these corporate league events
typically held in person before yes uh
they went virtual once coveted hit and
now we're doing sort of a weird kind of
mix some weeks they're online some weeks
they're in person lately they've been
online but uh especially for the
playoffs i'm gonna be back in person
here at the club
uh gonna be a lot of fun i'm looking
forward to it
okay rick to c1 for white
um i mean yeah this is fine honestly i
would have just played like bishop d3
straight away just waste no time go
pawns go let's win the game
rook c1 now black sacrifices the
exchange back
i am struggling to see how it's going to
make a difference here black i think is
sort of going for broke wants to play
something like f4 try to attack the king
in a last-ditch effort to make something
happen but i would be impressed if it
worked out i would be impressed
be very impressed
because you do not have a lot of time to
work with right this takes two moves and
it's hard to make any sort of threats
and two moves i guess
maybe
maybe you go bishop e4 next as black
um but i mean if you play b7 right away
like
there's just no time there's just no
time no time to make it work
okay this game i'm going to say is in
the bag let's check in on justini
linguine versus kyqz
so when we last left it here what did we
have we had this weird pawn sacrifice in
the french i remember all this
we had this traded bishops the knight on
e4 c4 was played okay this knight got
kicked away
we got a trade of pawns here and black
actually won a second pawn
okay some more night maneuvering ooh a
self pin here with queen to c5 not a fan
of that one at all you don't really want
to pin yourself up for no reason white
went for counter play down the f file
we got some more trades uh white
actually managed to take one of the
pawns back but black won this a2 pawn
and this also
appears to be a a pretty hopeless end
game
um pretty pretty hopeless here in my
opinion
okay but it's never completely hopeless
takes takes we have a mate and one
threat maybe he'll miss it
maybe he'll miss it also not hopeless is
the clock situation justini needs to
pick up the pace a little bit
you just want to keep things simple here
and
play with enough pace that you have
enough time to deliver checkmate
okay rookie one hits this knights that's
actually not a threat though of course
rick takes knight would blunder
checkmate
okay black goes for the g2 pawn
also reasonable
and again the the plan is pretty simple
here you want to go b3 b2b1 and what you
don't want to do is blender checkmate in
one
so one trick to avoid justini avoids it
okay well done
okay now maybe one more threat that you
have to deal with rook f8 rook f7 and
what do you actually play
what do you actually play
i guess you go king g6 rook g7 king f6
and i guess that's the way
yeah and justine plays it immediately to
his credit plays it immediately
well done well done to escape
that trick
okay rook back to f3 no trades allowed
um yeah now you want to save this knight
and that's why i didn't like this knight
takes g2 move um
again when you have like such a crushing
material advantage on the queen side uh
whenever you have spare time you just
want to spend all your time focusing on
getting those guys down the board you
don't want to get bogged down you know
putting your knight on an awkward square
giving your opponent tactics that you
have to deal with uh just to win a g2
punt right the g2 pawn doesn't matter if
our b-pawn becomes a queen
so i would like to just see the simple
b3
but instead
we've got this and black now is
threatening rook a1 to trade the rooks
and that should be the end of the game
yeah rook a1 gets those rooks off the
board the knight's not going to be able
to stop the onslaught on the queen side
especially with black's king coming in
so this should be winning for
justini
okay we did have a result in this game
as well john boyer did go on to win that
position
as expected very without any problems i
think
okay we'll assume justinia is going to
win this one even though he's a little
bit low on the clock i find it hard to
believe he won't so let's stick over
here and again with the weird openings
we have an alakan an alakans defense all
right let's see what's going on
okay e595 d6
knight f3 and d4 all all on the board
so this is going to be one of the tamer
lines in the alakin no four pawns attack
or any other garbage here uh black just
gets the the simple play with taking on
on e5 de5
okay continues now with e6
and the alkyne is one of those openings
where yes you end up with less space but
in lines like this at the very least you
get all your pieces developed right the
danger is when you have less space than
your opponents um you're you're not
going to end up with uh enough squares
to develop your pieces whereas in a line
like this you know at the very least
your pieces are getting off the back
rank which is is nice
d de5 not recommended yeah actually now
that you mentioned it that does look odd
don't they normally like attack this
pawn again somehow or okay maybe you
start with bishop g4 but you're normally
like you know doing some some something
right you're attacking this guy more uh
instead of resolving the tension
and nick would know all about resolving
tension from from i think a book he was
reading
um or was that nick i think that was
nick reading a book about uh keeping the
tension
okay it looks like justine did win that
game as well as expected
uh uh okay and the problem is being
explained apparently knight e5 is very
strong here with bishop c4 coming in
with bishop f7 ideas
um
fair enough and now that uh you
mentioned that i think there's some sort
of classic
you know 80 moves of theory along the
knight sacrifice in these kinds of lines
right am i am i remembering correctly
you go like 95 knight f7 queen h5 king
e6 that that kind of garbage um that's
that's the fun stuff that's the
corporate chestnut game i want to see
sounds like a useful book
well boy oh boy if i remember the title
i would tell you maybe nick can share
instead we get some more normal looking
position
and after b3 is this is this a pawn this
looks like a pawn i can i can take and
then after you take i can take again and
then i have more pawns than you
seems good seems worth doing in my
opinion
it was a local print in st louis in the
90s wow nick with the deep cuts okay
good luck finding that one then good
luck to you
okay knight f4 so just positional chests
here from john which goes knight f4 he's
got some some light squared pressure his
pieces again they all have squares at
the very least his pieces have squares
what more can you ask for
bishop b5 steps out of the threat of
knight takes e2
and it's about time that black castles
the king i think we've delayed it for
long enough here
it's about time to get this king castled
john might be considering queen takes d1
which at first glance
looks
like it might win
yeah maybe queen takes d1 which is very
good you remove the last defender of the
knight and then you get stuff like
knight h3 or bishop h3 followed or
bishop f3 followed by knight h3
and it seems like uh
seems like that should be quite good
yeah queen d1 played
queen d1 played
nice find by uh by john okay bishop c6 i
guess we just go b take c6 now
well i mean what else would we do
and now yeah we have our choice we have
our pick do we want to play knight h3
and leave the bishop on or just take on
f3 first so okay
john pig's knight takes h3 i like it
webster says i like books about
principles openings are best learned on
apps like chesapeal in my honest opinion
yeah
the the secret is that the things on
chessable are essentially books though
um
it is nice to have that that extra tool
of the the move trainer and things like
that but at the end of the day the the
usefulness is not in the moves in my
opinion it's in the ideas being shared
in in the text uh more so than the moves
a lot you get to understand you know why
uh these lines are the correct idea you
know what the correct idea is once
you're out of the theory you know what
is the plan in that kind of position
what am i actually trying to achieve
here and that's what's getting shared
through
through the text of the books
so rook d3 and i mean this just looks
winning for john
he's only up a pawn in this case but i
mean the bishops are going to be very
nice here and this yeah we can castle
our king any day now
weakness here for white weakness here
for white weakness here for white
weakness here for white gonna be tough
to keep everything together
so let's check in on our other board one
and see how we're doing in this game
um wow craziness craziness already looks
like we had a king's indian defense okay
a quick bishop g4
and ah one of these lines okay
and white just blunders the the c4 pawn
so
don't be shy about just retreating this
bishop back in a position like this
because you're gonna gain that tempo
back against that knight on e5 f4 is
gonna come with tempo at some critical
moment and i think in lines like this
white's actually pretty close to just
like straight up winning so uh would
have been nicer to see that
okay my i'm glitching out a little bit i
think okay we're back in back in control
my arrow keys stopped working but that's
okay
instead black did get to pick up that c4
pawn
and had some nice counter play although
already i'm starting to favor white
again and nope never mind we lost e4 no
longer favoring white here we have this
nice looking bishop on c6 and some queen
side pressure
but yeah black should be in control at
the end of the day okay we got b4
on the board
so
what's it all about is black actually in
control i think so knight e6 knight d4
hard to argue with black's total control
over the center here
how can you work on chest yourself uh it
depends on what level you are and what
your your weak points are
but
there's a lot you can do you can play
chess you can analyze your chess games
you can do tactics you can read books
my advice is always do what you find
is the most interesting because when
people
try to you know buckle down and say i'm
gonna study the parts of chess that i
hate because i need to get better uh
sometimes it works sometimes they study
them and get better but a lot of times
they quit because they don't like it uh
and if you quit you don't get any better
so that's always
priority number one
so queen to c4 makes a lot of sense here
for white you want to pin this knight
you don't want to let it get to that d4
square
and maybe i i
didn't give this idea enough credit we
can follow up with bishop d5 we're going
to have to play rook to e8 otherwise our
knight
dies okay blacks uses the other rook
but i think
black will have just enough time
to uh to escape here although actually
yeah rook ft8 may be no good because now
now we can actually take here if we use
the other rook we would maintain this
pin on the rook for another turn which i
think was very important that was going
to give us the time we needed to unpin
our king now after fe 5
might be big trouble for black okay
there's bishop b2 but then there's check
king h1
and what's going on
what is going on
i don't know but it looks very scary all
of a sudden very scary
the self pin
again maybe maybe not so good
if black does play the check any
recommendations for learning openings
well what we were just talking about
chestable i think is a great tool for
players these days
um
and opening books in general if you like
reading i think can be quite helpful
okay rook takes b2 uh black goes king g7
unpinning but i think it's a turn too
late we're gonna go rookie two that is a
skewer
boom boom
boom
and what to do what can you do
nothing you can do nothing
okay maybe
you actually play queen take c2 here
this is kind of funny i think queenie 2
is the best move and after queen takes
e2 you go knight f4 and then after the
queen moves away you get to
actually no you get checked so you don't
get to pick up this bishop so
no good after all no good after all
um so queen here instead
tries to make it interesting but i think
this simple way is correct here we just
go rookie six capture that knight
white's going to be up a piece
looks good for justini back from the
brink had an awkward opening but managed
to to find the way through
any book recommendations i mean it
depends on what opening you want to
learn you got to find an opening you
like
and then uh
and then maybe i can help
me personally i used
a book on the nimzo indian used the
nimzo indian move by move to get started
with that opening also here we just came
in on an awkward tactic looks like white
here is also losing a piece
all right let's go back to this one
now maybe this one isn't where it's at
after all
uh black at least has a pawn for the
piece in this position in this position
i think john has the extra pawns and now
the extra piece and
and now uh mc throws in the towel
decides to go ahead and resign so
a perfect night for john boyer of
enterprise going to going 2-0 for his
team
and that's going to leave us just with
the other board one here to follow
let's see what's going on rook to e8
we'll see if kyqz can bring it back from
the brink bring it back from the brink
wow
bet you didn't know i could rap on the
corporate chess league
so kyqz having a tough night so far
started off on won against uh mc in a
big upset he did manage to battle back
in round one
uh
to split that match but maybe you know
it's not going to be so easy to repeat
that same kind of comeback against
justini linguini
kg asks are these employees of the
companies competing yes so we are
currently looking at the edward jones
versus ascension match with justine
linguini
heading the team for edward jones and
kyqz heading the team for ascension
so kyqz is making it interesting at
least here he's got this pressure down
the e file white has to spend a couple
turns untangling
i don't love what he's going for here
with d5 d4 though to be honest with you
i would have preferred to see something
like um rick a4 and then maybe we can
bounce back a little bit uh start
pressuring actively over here on the
queen side d4 is actually serving to
hamper black stroke more than it helps
right you know europe cannot swing over
to the side of the board anymore
to make threats
now after rookie 5 i think it's going to
be simple yeah we just go to c1 no more
activity for black it's time to defend
passively and once you go passive in
these positions it's going to be going
to be tough
very american chess match well all the
teams are located in st louis so that
makes some sense
okay king to f6 now if i'm uh playing
with white here i want to
keep my pieces active find some way to
come after this this d-pawn so rook to
c4 looks like a good start but black can
actually bring in the king now
and yeah maybe it's not so easy after
all you know we get bishop f3 we get to
kind of uh cut this king off a little
bit but i don't know how
uh white's intending to deal with
something like rook d7 and pushing this
guy forward maybe we need to bring our
own king
okay rook f7 doesn't feel like the right
idea you know white wants to play king f
king e2 king d3 anyways or maybe even
king d2 leaving the light squares open
for the bishop
it's still up to justini to be able to
break through here though still up to
justini
bishop c6 to paralyze yeah so i like the
bishop on f3 better than c6 because i
like leaving this file open so we can
actually target this guy a little bit
and especially now after h6 i think
black is leaving behind some some more
problems
um okay justine finds bishop g4 instead
when this rook is actually overworked
and something will fall
now i think you gotta go rook f7 allow
this takes and try to invade get active
again but without the d-pawn i think uh
we're running out of hopes here we are
running out of hopes
arrow takes d4 okay we get rook f2 we
get our last hurrah
uh invading on the second rank but i
don't think it should amount to much
shouldn't amount to much here okay king
d6 actually allows this with check i
would have preferred to see uh king to
d5 looks kind of scary but against
bishop b6 then you just play king d6
um if i'm white here okay yeah he just
goes bishop f3 i mean anything is fine
it's all going to be good
okay rook a
two tries to pressure on the other side
of the board
and i can give it a check go rook c4 go
rook c6 even
and
should be pretty smooth sailing here for
justini
uh justini though you know eternally uh
kind of a time pressure addict tonight
he's he's always leaving himself just
enough time to get the job done so far
it hasn't come back to bite him
uh here in fact three minutes though
probably gonna be enough time especially
now that he finds this king e4 idea he's
actually invading with the king the
bishop and the rook hold absolutely
everything down they control you know
massive swathes of the board as well
makes it tough for for black to fight
back you know king g6 king h6 king g5
and probably resigns to be honest
probably resigns after that happens
might be time might be time to throw in
the towel h5 not going to be quite good
enough maybe he was hoping for some h6
pre-move g4 trying to stay in
stay in the fight but no such luck
these pawns do fall
and kyqz
desperate now
desperate
for some hope
but there is none the plan is simple we
go h4 we go h5 we go h6
we do this we go h7 we do this we go h8
c5
this is the this is the hope
black throws away the c pawn
uh you cannot take because rook's e1 is
check
and your rook would hang
so rook over to c1 instead and now at
the very least
black has a check which is more than he
could have said in in the previous
position so if you take here i think
white's actually intending rookie 6
maybe not but you know fun way to get
the last piece off the board so this
pawn is actually untouchable by both
pieces
so rook d4 or rookie 6 should be the
same thing here
either way is going to get the job done
rookie 6 is played by justini okay now
there's no more pieces i think i think
it's time i think it's time to give it
up yep we get resignation
and with that i think we are out of
games to follow let me see
if i can find any other ones
don't know that i'm going to be able to
though the round should be wrapping up
here i doubt we have too many more games
going on
let's see though let's see what we got
um looks like there's a few people still
online
i'm not sure if anybody's playing i
think we might have to be calling it a
night here let's see if i can find
some scores for you guys though because
we don't have the results of the round
what i do have are the results on board
one so john boyer wins both games on
board one for enterprise and justini
linguini wins both games on board one
for edward jones so if i had to guess
those two teams probably won but let's
see if i can make it official here
while you're looking at me
i will try and look some of these people
up
is that how you do it that is how you do
it okay
pendulum is playing a correspondence
game but not playing in live chess
okay so let's take a look here
kendalum goes 2-0 against vindy okay so
with that enterprise does defeat bayer
in their match
now hopefully uh it's going to be just
as easy for edward jones here
so i don't have to do this too much
let's see fishers of men is the board
too for edward jones oh and he's
blitz no he's still playing he must
still be playing let's see if we can
find him
we can find him it's a miracle okay
so he won his first game against maurice
gp and now this is one of the final
games in the round most likely uh up
against maurice gp
so let's see here so if fishersman wins
this he officially will have uh won the
match for edward jones
and if i can look up
paul frowan we might actually already
have a result as well
let's see here
no so paul lost his first game against s
gilmore
okay so now it is it's up to either paul
or fishers of men
one of them has to score
at least a half point if they can get a
half point out of the remaining two
games then edward jones will win the
match against ascension
but they have to they they can't lose
out otherwise they will tie the match
so what's going on here fishers of men
has the white pieces he has the extra
pawn he has a weird looking structure
over here on the queen side and uh
definitely the the worst minor piece
here the knight
not leaving you know a beautiful
impression on the position
so black has the extra pawn or sorry
black has has the dark squared bishop
that is going to be a good source of
play in the position
what white needs to do is find some way
to launch this guy up the board if this
guy gets a few squares further up the
board bishop's not going to matter the
only thing that's going to matter is
this age pawn
okay i like knight g2 i don't like the
trait of rooks by black you needed to
keep pieces on the board keep things
complicated but what is this rook f4 oh
i didn't look at the time i didn't look
at the time fishers of men has no time
and uh black picks up the two queen side
pawns
now h the h pawn is rolling we can just
barely stick our bishop on h8 in time to
stop it okay maurice wants to put the
rook there instead fair enough
now can can white make it happen with
eight seconds on the clock i have my
doubts i have my doubts okay there's a
check we need to bring our king over
we need the king here we need the king
to help
okay he's trying to keep the knight out
of g5 but now there's knights g6 knight
g6 has missed
uh knight g6 would have kept the game
alive bishop f6 we can take the rook be
up in exchange
instead 2.8 seconds on the clock i don't
think fischer's men is going to get to
do it i don't think he's going to get it
done
and yeah black wins on time okay
so with that
it was all up to paul frowan oh but he
has officially won his game so edward
jones just barely by a single point
manages to defeat ascension with paul
frowan on the last board getting the job
done and with that i believe we have all
of our results in for the for tonight's
uh so exciting action there at the end a
very close match between edward jones
and ascension you know that ascension
team they're they're tough they're
always in the mix they're always one you
have to look out for it always seems to
come down to the last game to determine
if you're good enough to beat that
ascension team
so with that you see the standings up
there on the screen that is how many
points the players the teams have won
here tonight so these will be added to
their existing scores ascension makes up
just a tiny bit of ground against edward
jones trying to overtake them in that
second place spot doherty despite not
fielding a full team scores more points
than bayer so they will maintain their
fourth place spot and their spot in the
playoffs for yet another week
and enterprise further extends their
lead thanks to their board one john
boyer going 4-0 enterprise actually with
a clean sweep of bayer in that last
round makes it tough makes it tough to
catch up
so with that
i think that is just about all we have
for you here tonight be sure to tune in
not next week but the week after for the
next edition of the corporate chess
league again if you want to get involved
yourselves uh email us at development
stlouischestclub.org we would love to
have some more teams in the events it's
always a lot of fun when we do these
and thank you all very much for watching
as always my name is caleb denby this
has been the corporate chess league and
i will see you next time
the 2022 chess season is off and running
join us in april for the first american
cup
world-class chess masters will gather in
the chess capital of america st louis
missouri to compete in a do or die
struggle for a combined purse of three
hundred thousand dollars
we will cover all the action live from
april 20th through april 29th
tune in for the best game in chess
streaming live
for more information visit us
uschestchamps.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you